let's talk about uh cop show cop show
i've been looking at these uh
these digital clips cop show and really
it's really funny
it's really funny and you and what's
what i love about it
is that it's this digital series where
you look like a guy who should be in a
new york cop show
you know what i mean you you look like
you you look like a guy
who should be there with the cup of
coffee making
those sort of jerry orback smart alec
comments and this is
a great takeoff of that genre and i
think it works because you are
that guy you are the guy that should be
in that show
and it so to me that's why it works well
we have a clip here
which will give everyone a very nice
taste
of what cop show is all about let's take
a look at that
right now yeah what do we got
female caucasian late 20s looks to be
possibly deceased
looks like a real nice girl apparently
somebody didn't think so
cut cut is that last line sound too mean
let's maybe just uh do a tick where we
lose the
the kick kick the corpse i don't feel
like our cop would do that right
on the next take i think we should show
the horror of murder
by getting a close-up on the eyes yeah
yeah i like that i like that a lot okay
guys so we're gonna go
uh tight in on the victim's eye no not
the victim's eyes
close up on my eyes
oh yeah i'm sure if you if you want that
we can do that uh guys
[Music]
the horror of murder yeah
do you look like you're having a lot of
fun making that
i have so much fun i could do that for
10 years if i could
if i had the money i mean i love it um
well let me get the word out on on
cop show all episodes of collins digital
series cop show
are now available to stream on his
youtube channel
huh yeah it's the only thing on my
youtube channel it's very easy to find
well don't say that make it sound like
it's a big going concern
there's a lot going on with your youtube
channel and if you're lucky you'll catch
this
learn how to play the game a little bit
you don't go that's all there is
that's all i got that's it it's
i like i like the equality of going
concern
it's a going concern it's a going
concern also
uh i said this to you before but you
know there's a lot of comedians out
there that
they crank out comedy books and i got to
tell you i look at them and i can tell
they did this in about 10 minutes
you're a great you're a great writer
you're a terrific writer
and um and you have this is a very
well thought out book of very funny
essays
about all the states in the united
states so uh check it out
uh colin's new book overstated a
coast-to-coast roast of the
50 states is available right now
and maybe if they turn it on the youtube
channel there'll be a plug for it
well yeah it's on the uh i'm putting the
book on the youtube channel
see because it's a going concern you
want people you want people to tune in